-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all
doing well tonight.
And, now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
President Biden today
traveled to New York.
Said New Yorkers,
"Oh, my God! Move!"
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview, Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis said
that the media's coverage
of Hurricane Ian was motivated
by a political agenda, adding,
"I mean, as soon as it was over
there was a rainbow
outside my window."
[ Laughter ]
[Mockingly]
"That's not political? Okay."
Georgia Senate candidate
Herschel Walker's campaign
has announced that since he
was accused earlier this week
of paying for
his ex-girlfriend's abortion,
it has raised
more than $500,000.
In fact, it's going so well,
Walker's thinking about asking
all his exes to come forward.
[ Laughter ]
FEMA announced yesterday that
phone operators from the IRS
have been brought in
to help the agency
handle the volume of calls
after Hurricane Ian.
So now getting help will be just
as easy as doing your taxes.
[ Laughter ]
Tomorrow is Russian President
Vladimir Putin's 70th birthday,
where he will blow out
the candles
and then push the cake
off a balcony.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump
said in a speech yesterday
that he is being targeted
by the FBI because,
"They want to silence me."
Hey, it's not their fault the
only way to truly silence Trump
is to sit him down
for a deposition.
[ Laughter ]
A new list
from "Fortune" magazine
has ranked CVS Health
President and CEO Karen Lynch
as the most powerful woman
in business --
because she's the only one
with the key to the razors.
[ Laughter ]
That's -- That's power.
A 17-foot-tall statue
was recently unveiled in Canada
of a giant hand holding a Cheeto
with orange dust
on the fingertips.
So the other statue
obviously looked like this.
[ Laughter ]
Two right hands.
It's a statue
with two right hands.
[ Laughter ]
The world's oldest living dog,
Pebbles, died recently
at 22 years old and 50 days.
"You son of a bitch!"
[ Laughter ]
It's a bummer I went
into that joke
laughing about
the weed fingertip statue.
I'm like -- "Ha ha ha ha!
The world's oldest dog died."
Wyoming Congresswoman Liz Cheney
spoke last night
at an event
at Arizona State University,
and because it was ASU,
she made sure to speak slowly.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, we have an issue here,
I want to admit.
Our head writer, Alex Baze,
went to University of Arizona,
and so he oftentimes
will write jokes
that are very unkind
to Arizona State University.
So I'd like to apologize to
anyone who went to that school,
who's currently going to that
school, and let's move on.
Um...
[ Laughter ]
Wyoming Congresswoman Liz Cheney
spoke last night
at an event
at Arizona State University,
though I'm not sure why
they needed a congresswoman
to read off the beer-pong rules!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
I mean, University of Arizona
is not Harvard, dude.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, so, we asked another
writer to cover this story,
because obviously Baze
cannot get above himself here
to do this.
And finally Mike Scollins --
Our good friend Mike Scollins
chipped in here.
And finally
Wyoming Congresswoman Liz Cheney
spoke last night at an event
at Arizona State University.
Well, at least everyone there
is used to not getting
their first choice.
You guys!
[ Laughter ]
Come on!
That was a monologue, everybody.